[Music]
10 most bizarre bathrooms from around
the world when you think of a bathroom
you usually think of something that's
pretty much the same everywhere you go
in the world for this video will show
you some i catching unusual and bizarre
bathrooms from across the world make
sure you watch this video to the end to
hear the story of Donald Trump and a
restroom that was not all it seems if
you've never visited us before make sure
you click on that subscribe button and
give us a thumbs up - today we're
showing you 10 most bizarre bathrooms
from around the world 10 the world's
most southerly bathroom ok so some of
the bathrooms we are talking about today
are quite clearly a bit bizarre when you
look at them but this one looks like a
normal men's bathroom that is until you
find out where it is you see this humble
restroom is the most southerly one in
the world located at the amundsen-scott
South Pole station in Antarctica
it's just 350 meters from the world's
southernmost point which means it was
the world's southernmost bathroom the
picture was taken by photographer Chris
Curtis who said he didn't believe there
was another bathroom in the world that
could compete for the efforts that went
into reaching the place where it was set
up and what it may lack in beauty it
more than made up for indignity keep in
mind the first person to reach the South
Pole Norwegian explorer Roald Amundsen
only did it in 1911 and you just might
see what he means with temperatures
getting as cold as minus 99 degrees
Fahrenheit we think it's not just the
most suddenly bathroom in the world but
it's almost certainly the coldest to the
station where it's held has space for
just 150 people although as many as 250
people make use of it in the Antarctica
summer with the extra population staying
in specially constructed thermal tents
outside the base nine mannequins cause
restaurant goers problems perhaps one of
the most crucial things when using the
bathroom is being able to feel relaxed
it should be a clean and private place
for you to use
now this next place in the city of high
one in northern China certainly doesn't
fall down on hygienic grounds but what
it did do was cause some distress for
male users the bathroom in a restaurant
features an installation of
realistic-looking models of women
wearing revealing lingerie
they were stood behind a glass wall
right in front of the conveniences
fittings which left a number of patrons
complaining that they were just not able
to go the reason one man said was that
it was very off-putting to have a woman
even made a classic staring at him son
Cowell said that he walked out of the
bathroom when he first entered it
because he initially thought that he had
ended up in the ladies rather than the
gents the weird installation ended up
going viral on Chinese social media and
it appeared that it wasn't just the
restaurant goers of Palawan who ended up
being put off by them we still aren't
entirely sure why the restaurant put
them there but hey even if people
complains about the bizarre bathroom
they still would have remembered the
restaurant and what they saw there ate
an aquarium and the restroom we think
this must be one of the most unique and
brilliant bathrooms in the entire world
the thing is it's not just a restroom
but it's an aquarium - the facility is
in the moominpappa cafe at the seaside
town of a casa Japan it's a ladies
bathroom and when you go into it you're
surrounded by water and not only that
but there's marine life for you to look
at - the entire room was built in a way
that would make the restroom users think
about swimming in the nearby Seto Inland
Sea because it's not just as private as
you'd expect a bathroom to be it's
perfectly silent it would have cost the
owners the equivalent of two hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars to build
think how many people must go and grab a
coffee and maybe something to eat
purely so they can experience this a
wonderful restroom that would have
probably recoups the cafe's costs pretty
quickly however there might be one
slightly odd thing the giant fish tank
contains a turtle and that turtle is a
male in the ladies restroom still there
haven't been any complaints from the
thousands of users who make use of this
very special bathroom but we can't help
but think that seeing all different
kinds of
marine life is a wonderful distraction 7
from beer kegs to bathroom in a time
when a lot of people are concerned about
the environment it's good to be able to
do your bit to reuse recycle and help to
save our planet that's exactly what one
company did when it came to fitting out
its new bathroom you see the firm in
question was a brewery so it had a lot
of metal barrels that were done with
holding beer rather than throw them out
the owners of Monteith brewery greymouth
new zealand fashioned them in to
bathroom fittings now visitors to the
brewery can take a break from their tour
and see what happens when the beer
making process is done and just what
happens to the kegs that can't be used
for holding drinks anymore we like them
they look a bit unusual and there's
something to tell people about but not
only that they connect the bathroom with
the building they're in and they might
make you think about how other companies
could reuse their old equipment and new
interesting and environmentally
conscious kinds of ways the brewery has
certainly done this in their bizarre
bathroom when you think how much it
might cost to have these scraps it makes
good business sense it's also a way of
giving people something that expect to
see in a brewery but putting in a rather
different place than usual 6 now you see
it now you don't one thing about most of
the bathrooms that were featuring in
this video here today is that they are
all unique they're the sort of things
that only exists in one place in the
world
this next one although it's still pretty
bizarre is a little bit difference of
those because it's one that can be
installed in your home it's secret is
that you don't know how it works it
could leave someone puzzled and feeling
as if they've gone into the wrong room
that's because this design made by
Italian company Repsol is what's known
as a disappearing bathroom there's a
toilet a shower and a basin for you to
make use of but they're disguised and
some smart and tasteful looking wooden
shelving units you just have to lift
them up and you'll get to the peace of
the bathroom that you'll need to use
there's also enough space to store
things like razors and
based and all the other things that you
might keep in your bathroom too and in
case you were wondering the wood in this
award-winning restroom designed by
Matteo Thun and Antonio Rodriguez is
specially treated so it becomes water
resistant that's very useful because
water from a shower can cause serious
damage to wooden fittings which is
another reason why this particular
design looks so unusual five from wrasse
fan to bathroom there's something
special in the combination between a
really cool pub and really great music a
friendly and welcoming atmosphere can do
a fantastic job of seriously enhancing
the sounds that you hear whether it's a
live act or music being played over a
jukebox
so one pub owner did something awesome
if possibly a little weird when he paid
tribute to his areas local music in his
venues bathroom the pub in the town of
Fryeburg Germany has an unusual set of
fittings in the shape of tenor horns the
traditional brass instrument which is
very heavily used in German folk music
is hung from the wall of the restroom
that makes it look less like a
convenient than it does a music shop or
maybe even a rehearsal studio the idea
of putting the instrument in the
bathroom came from the pub's landlord
Martin Hartman who said most of his
customers thought they were pretty
amusing although some musicians at the
drinking establishment were less likely
to see the funny side you have to admit
you might find that little off-putting
to see the tools of your trade used in
such an unusual fashion however we like
them and we think that they could well
get some positive word-of-mouth
spreading around about this pub and it's
bizarre bathroom for coffins in a clubs
bathroom if you run a restaurant or a
bar in a thriving City then you want to
make sure that you stand out from the
crowd
sometimes it's not just enough to have
the best offers or sell the nicest food
and drink when you have so much
competition to deal with so what 1 min
you did was make their bathroom a
bizarre and macabre ace by putting a
couple of coffins in there they are
full-size made of dark wood with an
orange background and they have a pretty
scary screaming
Ted molded into them the bar in question
lab do cathuria in the Macarena district
of Bogota Colombia has not appeared to
have lost any customers since they did
up there gents restroom in such a dark
and morbid fashions to be honest we
don't know whether we would be brave
enough to make use of this particular
bathroom those bats heads might be a bit
too scary then again we can totally get
it if you would want to visit logic
atheria just so you could pay a visit to
this crypt like facility it's certainly
bizarre and weird enough to warrant
paying a visit to if you were passing by
we wonder whether other places in the
area have been inspired and risen to the
challenge and put in their own themed
bathrooms three space bathroom the
bathrooms that we've been looking at
they've all got one thing in common
they've been right here on planet earth
but this particular restroom is designed
to be used in outer space the thing is
this is the bathroom on the
International Space Station although we
might think of astronauts as bold
explorers who take risks and take
humanity to new heights they are still
people at the end of the day and people
need to use the bathroom what scientists
from NASA had to do was to work out how
they could use a toilet in an
environment when it's just not practical
to use water think about it the lack of
gravity means water can't stay in the
bowl so engineers built comes and made
use of air flows to make a convenience
for space explorers that worked and was
hygienic too in case you were wondering
the facility has bars and foot straps
that keep the astronaut attached and
stop them from floating off in a
zero-gravity environment while an
intricate set of high-tech pipes go to
work and the most remarkable thing about
it might well be that it's a recycling
facility to creating vital drinking
water to help refresh and sustain the
intrepid space explorers to model legs
in front of sink well this one is just
plain bizarre at one venue people who
need to use the bathroom find themselves
greeted by sinks only in front of them
there's something you don't usually see
in the dead
rather than an empty space or a washroom
counter there are models of what appear
to be women's bodies from the waist down
vent over and what makes it even the
otter is that they are dressed in
underwear and what looks like fishnet
stockings and they're painted red and
wearing high heels the odd thing is is
that the bathroom itself looks pretty
classy with some rather nice chrome
fittings and dark-colored wash basins
there's some green liquid soap and the
room is topped off with some attractive
houseplants so the appearance of the
mannequin legs is a bit of a brainteaser
you have to ask yourself why are they
there where did they come from and why
did the club's management put them there
that said the venue in question doesn't
seem to have any complaints about the
bathroom legs and it's certainly eye
catching and we think it is sort of the
thing that people would talk about to
their friends let's be honest if you
went out to a popular nightclub and you
saw this bathroom don't you think that
you'd end up telling all your friends
about it later
one Trump bathroom isn't all it seems
when he said he was running for
president of the United States of
America Donald Trump attracted a wave of
controversy a lot of people loved him
while a lot of people really didn't so
as with all high-profile politicians he
was going to generate protests and it
certainly appeared that there was one
bathroom which took protesting the
president to a whole new level this
picture shows a mural of President
Trump's face however his mouth is
covered with a urinal and that is in the
design of the Rolling Stones famous
tongue and lips logo pretty powerful
stuff right but with this photograph all
is not as it seems you see rather than
being a strong protest against the
billionaire politician in bathroom form
it's actually a fake artist's William
Duke and Brandon Griffin teamed up to
combine a newspaper photograph of mr.
Trump with a wall of Belushi's bar in
the st. Christopher Inns hostel in Paris
France the image went viral before the
pair admitted what they'd done
Brandon Griffin said it started off as a
joke between the two friends before it
blew up on social media and made it onto
websites in
papers across the world but still we
wonder what sort of bathroom you design
if you were able to have the Photoshop
skills of those two men tell us in the
comments and that's it for 10 most
bizarre bathrooms from around the world
if you liked it be sure to check out our
video 15 random acts of genius vandalism
thanks for watching and remember to
subscribe
[Music]